[Musique]
c'est un projet qui est très éclectique
j'essaye de de combiner tout ce que
j'aime musicalement dans un même projet
c'est-à-dire le hip-hop et le rap j'ai
commencé par ça quand j'avais 16 ans le
jazz parce que je suis une chanteuse de
jazz à la base
so happy
[Musique]
et là ça me tenait à cœur de faire de
faire ma musique et de sortir mon album
avec mon univers et mon esthétique est
ce que ce que j'aime quoi
[Musique]
je peux parler de diverses choses
une recherche d'un bien-être parce que
je pense d'ailleurs que ma venue à la
Réunion en fait beaucoup partie je parle
aussi un peu de l'inquiétude de demain
enfin comme beaucoup c'est un sujet très
actuel je parle beaucoup d'amour
forcément
de l'attente de l'attachement
du temps qui passe
et qu'on ne rattrape plus et puis enfin
voilà je parle de choses qui qui
m'habitent quoi de choses qui me qui me
traversent et qui me questionne ouais
quelque chose qui m'amuse beaucoup à
faire c'est de rebondir d'un univers à
l'autre j'ai envie que mon projet se
soit un projet aussi très comment dire
que ce soit pas juste un concert mais
que ce soit un spectacle j'aimerais
je sais pas qui est des images qui est
qui est de la fumée qui est des objets
qui a un décor qui est quelque chose qui
fait que chaque morceau illustre un
tableau une scène et je pense que comme
tous les titres sont très différents il
est possible d'emmener les gens à chaque
fois dans un autre un autre univers quoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si le peu que je peux proposer peut
enjailler ta journée et faire que un
matin tu te lèves et que tu souhaites
bonne humeur ben déjà j'ai je trouve que
j'ai partagé beaucoup quoi et puis moi
ce que je souhaite c'est que que les
gens ressentent des choses qui voyagent
avec mes morceaux qui ce que ça leur
parle en fait que que et mes paroles et
l'ambiance même si
même si on se connaît pas même si on
sait jamais rencontré c'est ça c'est
l'échange c'est façon c'est la musique
c'est c'est unique